البيئه همم يتشارك فيها الجميع ولا ولا
تعترف بالحدود السياسيه البيئه هي يعني
مشاركه بين جميع همم يعطيك مثلا مثلا همم
العواصف الترابيه التي تتبعه على المملكه
همم غالبيه بالقوسين الاقاليم العواصف هي
من جنوب غرب العراق عجيب هناك منطقه
متداوله بيئيا
وتعرضت الاجهاد بيئي
عندما عند طبعا
النماذج الرياضيه وصور الاقمار الصناعيه
تثبت ذلك
وقد طرحت في اكثر من همم وهناك عدد من
الدراسات العلميه التي تشير الى هذه
المنطقه بانها مصدر للتربه والغبار التي
تؤثر على المملكه العربيه السعوديه ودول
الخليج لذلك انا اعتقد ان التعاون
الاقليمي في هذا المجال هو الحل
ل همم يعني همم لايقاف هذا التدهور في
الاراضي العيساوي ضمن مبادره الشرق الاوسط
الاخضر في هذا المناطق الجافه التي تثير
الاتربه في العراق استفاد العراق اولا
ناحيه اعاده تاهيل البيئه والطبق الزراعيه
الرعويه واستفاد الدول الجوار ايضا بالضبط
المبادره طرحه استعاده 200 مليون هكتار من
الاراضي المتداوله طيب ما الذي يمنع ذلك
انا اعتقد انه يعني لابد للتعارف انا ما
ما اعتقد انه لابد يكون
الجار الكبير لهم ربما لا يسمح لهم اللي
هو جار الجار الطيب الجار الايراني الجار
الايراني عندما يحتاج اللي همم
البحيره اورما لجا الى فنانين هوليود حتى
يثيرون مشكله بيئيه عنده في تملح همم
بحيره فلذلك لا جاء الى دي كابريو همم
والنبي الايراني في جنوب العراق